الان الى فقره التحليل العسكري مع حسن
جمول واللواء فايز الدويري حسن اذا
الجزيره حصلت على فيديو مما جرى في
الشجاعيه وكذلك في خان يونس حسن فعلا عبد
القادر وبالتحديد
هذان الفيديو س يستحوذان على التحليل
الاكبر في سياق هذه النافذه الجديده
للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على
قطاع غزه وفيها كالعاده نستضيف المحلل
العسكري اللواء فايز الدويري مرحبا بك سيد
فايز لكن قبل ان نغوص في تحليل المشاهد
التي وزعتها كتائب القسام اضافه ايضا
لمشاهد وزعتها سرايا القدس سننتقل الى
الخريطه التفاعليه مع عبد القادر عراضه
لشرح المجريات الميدانيه على مستوى
المعارك اكان تلك التي حصلت معارك عنيفه
في الشمال او حتى في الجنوب قبل ان ن
ننتقل الى المشاهد الحيه بالفعل حسن
سنحاول ان نختصر الصوره والمشهد ولكن
تطورات لافته على كل الاصعده شمالا وجنوبا
ولعلنا ننطلق من المنطقه الشماليه الجيش
الاسرائيلي اعلن عن اضافه لواء الى هذه
المنطقه المنطقه التي نقول بانها منطقه
لازالت ملتهبه رغم حديث الجيش الاسرائيلي
اكثر من مره بانه سيطر فيها او كاد ان
يطبق على مناطقها الرئيسيه ونشير بالاساس
الى جباليه ومخيم جباليه لعلنا ربما نشير
الى اخر التطورات باعلان كتائب القسام عن
استهداف اليات هنا في منطقه جباليا البلد
استهداف اليات لما نتحدث عن اليات نتحدث
عن دبابات نتحدث عن جرافات في هذه المحاور
اذا تطور لافت هنا في منطقه الش الشمال
وتحديدا في جباليه لو انتقلنا ربما الى
الجهه الجهه الغربيه الشماليه الغربيه
لمدينه غزه ربما هناك ايضا تطورات في
الصفطاوي هذه المنطقه التي
شكلت كانت من مناطق التوغل الاسرائيلي في
اكثر من مره خلال بدايات الحرب وتقدم
الدبابات الاسرائيليه كان عبر هذه المحاور
الجديد هو اعلان ايضا كتائب القسام عن
استهداف فها لمروحه اسرائيليه وذلك بصاروخ
من نوع سام 18 اذا استهدافات في هذا
الاطار ربما الحديث ايضا لكتائب او لسرايا
القدس ايضا عن اشتباكات تقول بانها
اشتباكات ضاريه ومن المسافه الصفر في حي
الشيخ رضوان ولكن ايضا على مستوى محور
التفاح تاتي هذه التطورات بينما كان الجيش
الاسرائيلي ايضا اعلن عن مقتل ثلاثه من
لواء جفعاتي وربما هذا مؤشر على ازدياد
عدد القتلى في صفوف هذه الالويه التي تشكل
نوعا ما راس الحربه في العمليات القتاليه
للجيش الاسرائيلي في الشمال ولكن ايضا في
مناطق اخرى لو انتقلنا الى
منطقه جنوب غزه وتحديدا الى المنطقه
الوسطى لعلنا ننطلق مء الشجاعيه وكنا
تابعنا مقاطع فيديو نشرها الكتائب القسام
وذلك ل وذلك هذه عمل الاستهداف التي طالت
قوات اسرائيليه هنا في الشجاعيه شاهدنا
المقاطع الفيديو ولكن كانت ايضا هناك
عمليات استهداف لمناطق في المناطق الوسطى
بالخصوص في مناطق جحر الديك ولكن ايضا في
البريج وغيرها من المناطق الوسطى اذا
تطورات على المنطقه الوسطى والجنوبيه ولكن
ايضا في الشمال شكرا لك عبد القادر
مباشره مشاهدينا ننتقل الان
لمتابعه تلك المشاهد
التي وزعتها كتائب القسام للمعارك الضاريه
في خانيونس نتابعها اولا قبل الحديث
عنها وكور حجه الانيه
حبيب
النبي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
b
k
[موسيقى]
بس
رميت اذ رميت ولكن الله رمى يا رب اننا
لسنا من نرمي ولكنك انت من ترمي يا رب يا
رب اني ارجوك اني ارجوك ان توفق الرميه
ونحن ما خرجنا الا ابتغاء
[تصفيق]
سبيلك الله اكب الحمد لله انفجرت اقسم
بالله
ولعت ولعت الحمد لله ولعت الحمد لله ولعت
يا رب لك الحمد يا ار يا ار يا ار الحمد
لله الحمد
[موسيقى]
لله
الله
اكبر والله قتلتهم وهم بطلعوا
منها اذا سيد الفاز دويري هذه المشاهد هي
مشاهد خاصه حصلت عليها قناه الجزيره
للمعارك في خان يونس في
البدايه الاصل في الموضوع عندما نشاهد هو
المسافه القريبه جدا ما بين المقاتلين
والهدف اولا اقصى مدى مؤثر لهذا السلاح
130 متر وبالتالي حتى تكون الاصابه دقيقه
ومحققه يجب ان تكون دون 130 متر ام
وبالتالي قد تكون على بعد 50 او 70 او 80
متر من الهدف حسب المكان الذي يوجد به
الهدف لانه في بعض الحالات قد تكون على
مسافه 30 متر عندما تكون في مناطق مبنيه
وقد تكون على مسافه 130 متر لكن اكثر من
ذلك لا تستطيع لكن هذا واضح انها قريبه
جدا من مسافات ق من مسافات قريبه وتم يعني
يبدو كان هناك اكثر من اليه وتم مهاجمه
اكثر من هدف لانه كانت اللقطات لا لا اقول
انها مركبه لكن كانت متتاليه هذه هنا في
هذه الحاله استهداف دبابه من حاله الحركه
لاحظ عرضت صورتها في في مجال الرؤيه
للكاميرا ولكنها فجرت على بعد حوالي 50
متر من من الانطلاق اي بمعنى اخر المصور
كان في زاويه وم والرامي كان في زاويه في
زاويه
اخرى هنا استهداف قوه بعبوه مضاده للافراد
الصوره واضحه جدا على عكس ما ينشر جيش
الاحتلال هنا عرض الهدف الان يعرض الرامي
ويعرض الاطلاق ومن ثم نرى
النتيجه لاحظ
الانفجار
نعم الاصو مضاده للافراد
نعم
قص جندي من قوات الل هذه مجموعه من
الجنود هنا عمليه الاخلاء والنقال موجوده
مشاهده التصوير من مكان
قريب يعني يلاحظ هنا وهذه نقطه انه كان
بالامكان ايضا استهداف
هؤلاء الان لماذا لا اجابه لدي الان لا
اجابه لدي لماذا لم يتم استهداف
لا املك الاجاب ولا استطيع ربما ك كي لا
يكشف مكانهم مثلا لا استطيع ان اعطي رايا
في امر لانه واضح انه بعد الاستهداف
المقاتلون بقوا مكانهم وهم يصورون اخلاء
القتله والجرح يكون قد يكون هي المجموعه
من عده اشخاص عفوا لكن هذه ايضا اليه
ناقله النمر نعم ناقله النمر ايضا من
مسافه قريبه من مسافه قريبه لاحظ في اي
مجموعه تجد عندك رجل الاستطلاع عندك
الرامي تجد المساعد وتجد
المصور المجموعه فيها اربعه اشخاص في بعد
اطلاق النار قد ينسحب قسم منها من اجل
الامان
والسلامه وبالتالي قد يكون بقي المصور
والتقط اللقطه النهائيه بعد مغادره
المجموعه هكذا قد تكون التعليمات لهم لانه
سمعت في احد الفيديوهات التعليمات كانت
واضحه بكلمات محدده وصارمه صوت صور الجنود
كما يبدو
ولعوا طيب هذه معارك خانيونس مشاهد حصلت
عليها الجزيره لنتابع
سننتقل الى مشاهد من الشجاعيه لمعارك من
الشجاعيه ايضا مشاهد حصلت عليه الجزيره
هذه اعاده لمعارك خان يونس اعاده لخان
يونس لانه لاحظ هذا تجمع اليات اكثر من
عمليه اطلا لكن ربما ننتقل
اي الى معارك الشجاعيه
الشجاعيه هذه الشجاعيه على الخريطه فقط
للتوضيح
وهذه دبابه
الصور لاحظ هذا
الرامي
اها هذه قذيفه الياسين 105 نعم نعم الان
وضع المدى 100 100 متر كانه بناء على
ال مجريات المعركه لانه في البدايه نشر ان
المسافه له المؤثره 130 متر لكن من
البدايه اشاروا ان الم المسافه المثلى 100
متر لكن المسافه القصوى
والمؤثره استهداف اخر هذه جارفه
نعم ام يعني انتد ما تتحدث عن يجب ان يكون
الرامي على مسافه 100 متر من دبابه
محصنه اي لديها كل وسائل الحمايه نعم يعني
ما هذه الجرعه والاقدام والشجاعه والتضحيه
لدى لدى لدى المقاتل هنا رصد لجنود
اسرائيليين دخل احد المب هذ هذه لقطه
مميزه هل تعلم لماذا ام يوجد فيها قناصين
عدد اثنين ويقابلهم قناص من المقاومه
القناص كان هو الاسبق واستخدم التي بي جي
و يعني
قناص يستهدف قناص ليس جنود عاديين لانه
البنادق اللي حملوها بنادق قنص واليه
القتاليه كانوا يراقبوا
يتحروا لكن جاء الامر من غير مجموعه من
جنود الاحت من المكان الذي لم يحتسبوا هذه
مجموعه وهذا الحديث اعتقد عن
العشره نعم حديث عن العشره نعم تي بي
جي هذه مع هذه هذه التعليمات الان كيف كيف
تعطى التعليمات للتصوير والمراحل التي يمر
بها المقاتلون مقاتلو القسام تكوين المجمو
هذ هذه الحركه وكان هناك في اوامر واضحه
لاحظ هذه اللقطه الهدف هذ مصور نعم الهدف
صور بالطريق عرض بالطريقه العاديه ثم عرض
من شاشه الكاميرا ليثبت لك حقيقه التصوير
و حقيقه المكان هذه نوع من التاكيد على
المصداقيه كانت التعليمات
واضحه حدد الاتجاه اليه
الحركه الفواصل ما بين الاعداد واتخاذ
المكان المناسب المحدد لهم ومن ثم استهداف
الهدف والعوده طيب وبالتالي لكل لكل شخص
منهم هذا مساعد الرامي هذا مساعد الرامي
في كثير من الحالات ي يكون جاهزا
في حال اصابه هذه قذيفه التي بي جي تي بي
جي الياسين التي بي جي الان في كثير من
الحالات لا تكون الاصابه تؤدي الى انفجار
الاليه لانه الانفجار الكبير اللي نراه
ترى هو من تاثير انفجار القناب المساعد
اعطى
الرامي القذيفه وهو يصوب نعم
لل وذ المساعد يساعد في عمليه التلقيم كما
تقال ويساعد ايضا بالرشاش بعد تنفيذ الم
السؤال السؤال هنا لماذا برايك الان يعني
اي صورت القسام هذه المشاهد بهذه الطريقه
وكيف يتم
اي العمل او الاجراءات من اجل الوصول الى
الهدف لماذا برايك يعني هذه عندما تعرض
لانه لا بد ان يصل ان ان تصل الى جزء من
ال من المجتمع مجتمع الكيان الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي هذه تحمل مصداقيه عالي جدا كانه
يقول لهم هذا مصير
ابنائكم هذا المصير المتوقع امم لانه صور
لا لا مجال للشك في صدقيتها انا اسال عن
الاجراءات يعني في اي يكاد يكون الفيديو
الاول الذي تظهر فيه اجراءات العمليه من
البدايه الكاميرا المساعد الرامي كيف تتم
كيف يتلقون التعليمات هذا هو السؤال يعني
ما الهدف
من نشر ه الرد على الفيديوهات المقابله ام
الفيديوهات المقابله لا تبين الا جزئيه
محدده جيش الاحتلال الجنود يطلق النار
النار باتجاه ما ونراهم يتحركوا في الشارع
بنسبه امان عاليه ويطلقوا النيران او
نشاهدهم موجودين داخل مبنى ويطلق النيران
من اسلحه متعدده لكن على ماذا يطلقها غير
واضح الصوره غائبه هنا كانه تحدي ل جيش
الاحتلال اذا كان لديك معلومه حقيقيه
وتصور في ميدان المعركه وتصور لحظات
الاشتباك تفضل طيب الم يلفتك
يعني هذا الهدوء من المقاتلين لا لم لم
افاجئ بكل بساطه لم تفاجا مفاجاه هل تعلم
لماذا ام كم سنه وهو يتلقى تدريب في بعض
التقديرات انا قرات بعض التقارير خمس
لننسى الفتره السابقه التحضيريه نتحدث عن
فترات تدريب حقيقي ترقى الى خمس سنوات
اعداد عقدي اعداد بدني اعداد نفسي اعداد
مهاري فردي اعداد مهاري ضمن مجموعه العمل
هذا عندما خمس سنوات وهو يتلقى تدريبا
وبالتالي في الخلفيه الذهنيه لاي مقاتل
منهم مجازر غزه المجازر هذه المجازر تجعل
من اي مفرد مقاتل عنده الاستعداء هو يقول
لك لسان حاله وهنا اتحدث نيابه او هكذا
اقرا لست افضل من 80,000 بين قتيل وجريح
طيب دعني انتقم لدماء اهلي ا نعود للسؤال
عن نقطه سبق ان اضانا عليها
كثيرا هؤلاء المقاتلون يتحركون في اماكن
مدمره في اماكن دخل اليها جيش الاحتلال
عمليا احتلها يعني هم هو دخلها لم
يحتلها يعني الى لم يسيطر عليها ولكنه دخل
اليها ودمرها ايضا لكن رغم ذلك رغم ذلك
هناك الاتصال ما زال موجودا بين المقاتلين
هناك تنسيق يعني هناك مجموعه تقول من
اربعه افراد يتمكنون من الخروج امام جنود
الاحتلال يهيئون عملهم يتصلون بالقياده
ومن ثم ياخذون الاوامر وينفذون في منطقه
تعتبر محتله نعم يا سيدي الان كان واضحا
التعليمات التي صدرت في احد الفيديوهات
الان لسان ح يعني كمحلل اقول ق لك انه
عندما اصدر اليهم التوجيه هذا لديه كم
كافي من المعلومات حول الهدف وطبيعته
ونوعه و
لحظه توفره خاصه اذا كان معدات متحركه
وبالتالي في الوقت المناسب يتحدث الى
المجموعه
واجباتكم المكان الفلاني الهدف كذا متوقع
ان يمر في الوقت كذا وكذا وكذا العمل
الرامي في حال الهدف المتحرك هذا افترض
الهدف متحرك الرامي يجب ان يكون ثابت لا
يمكن للهدف ان يكون متحرك والرامي يكون
متحرك لماذا لانه لا يملك سلاح فيير اند
فورجت لا يملك نعم ان ان يسدد ويرمي وال
قذيفه تتتبع الهدف لا هذه رمايه مباشره
عيان يجب ان لاحظ الان يكون دور رجل
الاستطلاع ما هو دوره ان يتتبع حركه الهدف
لحظه بلحظه ويشعر وياتي دور المساعد في
التلقيم والمساعده والرامي في الرم قبل
قليل كنت تشير الى ان هذه المشاهد هي ببعض
تفاصيلها ترد بشكل مباشر او غير مباشر على
مشاهد
يوزعها جيش الاحتلال نعم نريد ان نتابع
بعض المشاهد التي وزعها جيش
الاحتلال ننتقل الى مشاهد الجيش
الاسرائيلي هذه هي هؤلاء الجنود يتحركوا
في منطقه ما بغض النظر ولنفترض انها في
خاني لنفترض هو لم لم يحدد لم اشاهد اشاره
ها هو يترقب دخل داخل
المبنى ها هو يتحرك لا يوجد لا يوجد اي
حركه
وهذه نتجاوزها لاحظ الان يخرج ال الطابق
الثاني لا نسمع انا لا اسمع العيارات
الناريه اذا كنت انت تسمعها تساعدني الان
نلاحظ هو يرمي على ماذا يرمي اين
الهدف هل الهدف البنايه اذا كانت البنايه
ليعرض لي صوره المقاتل الم يتم عرض صوره
جندي
الاحتلال في كل الافلام خاصه في عمليات
القنص هنا هو يطلق النيران باتجاه هذه
البنايه اذا انا لن اساعده وافترض وجود
مقابل له واتحدث نيابه عنه لياتين
[موسيقى]
بالصوره يعني حتى المصور هنا يبدو اكثر
توترا هذه عم انا اقول هذا هو تصوير من
جانب واحد ولا يوجد عدو هذا يصور في منطقه
خلفيه فقط كارسال رساله الى الداخل
والداخل اليمين المتطرف يقبل بما هو دون
ذلك لانه عمليه صراع سياسي هل تبقى هذه
الحكومه ام تسقط هذه الحكومه فيمكن
التجاوز عن كثير من الهفوات هكذا اقرا
المشهد سواء الذي صور او رده الفعل من قبل
المتلقي لكن بالمقابل هناك رافضين
لاستمرار هذه الحرب وهناك انشقاق واضح جدا
ما بين
رباعيه مع التعليق الذي
اي يعني نسمعه والتكرار عاده في ما نشاهده
بصور الجيش الاسرائيلي بماذا تفيد هذه
الصور حتى في الداخل هذه الصور يعني لا
استطيع ان اجيب على هذه النقطه تحديدا ما
هي رده الفعل لكن رده الفعل هناك تخضع
لاعتبارات اخرى اهمها الاعتبارات السياسيه
اليمين المتطرف جماعه بنك فيروس موتش وما
شابه ذلك يتقبل اي شيء بينما في المقابل
انا يعني كنت اقول لك ان هناك انشقاق بين
رباعيه المجلس الع عسكري اثنين مقابل
اثنين وزير الدفاع ونتنياهو يحاول الهروب
الى الامام من اجل استحقاقات معينه الا
يمكن الا يمكن افتراض هنا ان ما يقوم به
الجيش الاسرائيلي هو عمليه تمشيط لمناطق
دخلها يعني عندما يدخل الى مناطق تكون
فيها المقاومه
ويتمكن من التوغل فيها من الطبيعي ان يقوم
بعمليه تمشيط واسعه للمناطق خصوصا عندما
نشاهد نشاهد الجنود على السلالم وهم
يدخلون الى الى المان في ادبيات الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول انه يعتمد مبادئ عمليات
التمشيط فيما يتعلق ب الاف ام الامريكي
الكتب
النشرات الامريكيه واذا تحدثنا عن عمليات
التمشيط حسب الاف ام الامريكي اول نقطه
اللي هو الحفاظ على حياه المدنيين فاذا هو
لا يتبنى ذلك المفهوم علما ان الامريكيين
لا يتقيدوا به بصوره كبيره لكن لنفرض ان
عمليه تمشيط هو لا يقول عمليه تمشيط لا
يقول تنفيذ عمليات ضد المقاومه ويطلق
النيران على اهداف وهميه غير مرئيه ثم
النقطه الابعد من ذلك اين هم مقاتلي
القسام ام هلهم فوق
الارض لا تحت الارض ربما يفترض انهم فوق
الارض لماذا افترض لا افترض شيء غ عقلي لا
يقبله هو موجود تحت الارض لانه لو كان فوق
الارض لا بلغت نس الخسائر فيهم عاليه جدا
ولم يستطيعوا اداره المعركه حتى هذه
المعركه حتى هذه اللحظه المعركه تدار
بنجاح وبداء متميز انا هنا لا ادافع انا
هنا اوصف هنا اوصف المعركه بالامس
الصواريخ انطلقت من قلب المنطقه التي كانت
فيها يحتدم القتال اذا دعني اقول المقاتل
تحت الارض طيب يخرج في اللحظه المناسبه
للتعامل مع هدف وهذا عمليا يعني يصعب على
جيش الاحتلال لا صح من المستحيل عليه
تحقيق اهدافه في القضاء على على المقاومه
بهذا الشكل
طيب دعنا ننتقل من صور الجيش الاسرائيلي
الى صور خاصه لها علاقه بصاروخ سام 18
صاروخ الذي اسقط طائره نعم تم استهداف
طائره عموديه وفي الكتابات انها الطائره
رقم اثين منذ بدايه الحرب هذا الصاروخ
يعود
الى القرن الماضي صنا روسيه المدى الفعال
له 5000 5000 متر
ويطلق من الكتف يعمل بالاشعه تحت الحمراء
واصابته اي يعني للاهداف الجويه ذات التي
تطير على ارتفاعات تسمى ارتفاع [__] منخفض
او [__] يسمى في بعض الادبيات عمليا قديم
نعم يعود الى
1983 83 يعود الى يعني بدايه ثمانيات
القرن الماضي وبالتالي هو جاء سلسله تطور
بدات بسام واحد و صعودا في في الحرب 67 73
كنا نتحدث عن سام اثنين وثلاث ثم ظهر سام
المحمود 6ه وسبعه على اليه ثم بدات صواريخ
سام الكتف وصولا الى 18 وحتى ثمنه قرات في
بعض المصادر 6000 دولار تكلفته يعني ليس
بصاروخ الرخيص وبالتالي استخدامه يجب ان
يكون من قبل فرد مدرب فرد مدرب وماهر خاصه
في ظروف مثل ظروف كتائب المقاومه المحاصره
منذ عام 2006 حصار مطبق حصار 90% ومن 2013
بنسبه 100% عموما هو يستخدم الان ضد
طائرات الهليكوبتر ضد الطائرات الح ل ليس
ضد الطائرات الحرب لانه هي اقل يعني اقل
سرعه ابطا
منخفضه يمكن اكتشافها بسولي حتى من خلال
الصوت قبل قان توصل الصوت اسرع منها
وبالتالي يكون امام الرامي فرصه لكن اذا
اردت استخدامه امام الطائرات الاخرى
الطائرات معظمها سيكون يطير على اعلى من
هذا الارتفاع اثنين التقنيه ونظام الفلرز
في الطائرات ال كما قرات في الطائرات
المجنحه اكثر فعاليه وتقدما من الانظمه
الدفاعيه الخاصه بالطائرات العموديه ام
طيب اي هو استهدفت استهدفت به الطائره
استخدم
لكن سقطت ام لم تسقط هذا الموضوع انا قل
انا انا قلت استهدفت استهدفت لم استطع لا
استطيع ان اجزم نعم لانه قد تكون استهدفت
ولم تسقط و حتى ياتينا خبر ي لكن عمليا
سرايا القدس كشفت عن معلومه وطبعا لها
اهداف من كشفها لهذه المعلومه من المؤكد
الان رح يكون هناك حذر كبير في استخدام
الطائرات العموديه اي لانه سيكون هناك
توقع لاستهدافها بصواريخ اخرى بما انه هذه
المره الثانيه التي تستخدم بها قد يكون
نوع من التهديد الاضافي نعم التهديد
الاضافي لطائرات الهيليكوبتر نعم انا اقول
يعني انا قصدت التحديد الاضافي على حركه
الطائرات يعني لانه الان استخدامه هي
رساله التقطت من الجانب الاخر ان المقاومه
لديها صواريخ اذا عليهم ان يراعوا ذلك
طبعا هو عندهم من حيث المبدا هي مزوده
بصواريخ ه الفير مداها الاقصى 11 كومر هذا
مد 5000 مت نعم اذا
اي
اي ل للتوضيح هنا ال سام 18 ايجلا مضاد
للطيران محمول على الكتف المقاومه كتائب
القسام وهنا ربما اخطات في الاشاره كتائب
القسام هي الت وليس سرايا القدس هي التي
اي استخدمت هي التي اعلنت عنه وطبعا
الموضوع يعني فيه الكثير من التح ك كذلك
استخدم سلاح اخر قد يطلق عليه قاذفات
اللهب ومداه الاقصى 2000 متر والمدى
الحديث لغايه 800 متر
يكون القنبله تسمى القنبله الحارقه تصدر
يتكون سحابه من غازات عندما تشتعل وتنصر
تكون ح درجه حرارتها عاليه جدا هذا كمان
سلاح استخدم للمره الاولى في هذا اليوم
وقد بضلاله على ونشاهد نتائجه في الايام
القادمه اذا ما اذا كان موجودا بكثره وتم
استخدامه بكثافه بما انك تتحدث هنا عن
الطائرات الهليكوبتر الطائرات العموديه
فقط للاشاره هنا انه وكان اسرائيل يعني ال
بطلبها من الولايات المتحده طائرات اباتشي
ولم يوافق ولم تتم الموافقه على هذا الطلب
وكان هناك يعني مشكله ما ل لد الجانب
الاسرا اعتقد انه لدى اسرائيل يعني بعض
المصادر اشارت يوجد لديها 48 طائره
اباتشي وانه كانت نقطه الغرابه وتحدثت
بالامس انه في الوقت الذي تطلب به طائرات
اشي في الوقت الذي تدعو الطيارين
المتقاعدين وحتى سن
ال5 بالعوده والالتحاق بال بالجيش جيش
الاحتلال لان الطيارين الحاليين بداوا
يواجهوا مشكله تتمثل بالطيران والبقاء
داخل الطائره اكثر من اربع ساعات يوميا
مما بدا يسبب الارهاق والتاثيرات
والاسقاطات النفسيه الان عدم عدم الموافقه
لا اعتقد انها ستكون قاطعه جازمه لكنها لي
ذراع حتى يخضع نتنياهو للتوجهات الامريكيه
حول اعاده صياغه الاهداف وتحديد اطار
الحرب الزمانيه ما ما تشير اليه اسرائيل
تمتلك سربين من
هذه طاره قرات بالامس نعم شكرا جزيلا لك
اللواء فيز الدويري الخبير العسكري على كل
هذه المعلومات